move on
cam for marketing move on is Obama gay
needing attention over a old letter
what I should read that again anyway now
we'll just keep going the newer post
obtained a redacted portion of a
handwritten letter the former president
sent to his then College girlfriend Alex
McNear Alex a back in 1982. he talked
about his quote androgynous mind and
wrote and I'm quoting Obama here I make
love to men daily but in the imagination
uh cat this is is fantasizing
it's fantasizing about having sex with
men gay
[Laughter]
well as an expert in man on man gay sex
that's why I asked you I think it's so
horrible that somebody released this
yeah I know something you say when
you're 21 people are gonna be like what
did you mean when you were 21. he's 21
saying stuff in a letter I I how do they
get these exactly I just I'm like
sitting there sweating thinking about
everyone I ever sent a text message to
when I was 21. I don't make me
sympathize with Obama oh I I that's easy
to do in this situation yeah what tires
well my blackness won't allow me to
comment on this
listen I can only assume he really
wanted to get out of the relationship
really bad yeah
and
I I can relate because it was I was in a
relationship to where every time I tried
to leave the right way it was just was
not going to happen so just said I'm gay
I couldn't but the problem was I'm not
you know I'm not as civilized as I am
now
I had different theories of of that
lifestyle back then I was so I was gonna
say it so she would leave and I was like
I'm
I'm uh
I'm just gonna try to work this out a
little longer I couldn't say it so it
had to be really bad yeah for him to say
that because if he says that
the woman typically will overthink it to
death and like every time we're together
do you think of men and then he'll say
yeah and she'll be like well I can't be
with you anymore but I'll I can't help
it and it's not her fault and it's not
his fault yeah he was born that way yeah
it is really the
Gaga's no one loses and she'll say like
we can be friends and he'll be like yes
we can that's true we'll go shopping we
will go shopping
um at some point Kennedy there was no um
comment yet from the former first lady
although insiders say that Michelle told
Barack from now on he can open his own
jars
okay
I'm gonna have to disagree with Tyrus
yeah and I will tell you why I think
this young woman was like I can't sleep
with you because you're just too
straight like I the guys that I sleep
with they have to be like somewhat
androgynous and I have to know that
they're open enough to sleep with other
guys and he was like well in the
imagination and then I did a little
digging Greg because you know I love to
do I'm America's sweetheart and one of
her most revered journalists yes the
imagination is actually the name of a
gay bar in Glendale
sex with men in the imagination yeah
in the back of the imagination break
room both work something that young dumb
dudes would do to try to get it out or
to get in yeah I might be I'm confused
can you help me figure it out yes I
might be you know um
Joe I imagine things got uncomfortable
around the Obama dinner table when this
happened but not because of the letter
because they were eating a dog
foreign
the other joke was way worse
I I would say if you're imagining having
sex with men daily probably not
something you send in a letter to your
girlfriend yeah that's maybe something
you write on a note that you push
underneath a stall door at a bus station
um I ca I can't judge him too harshly
because many times I've imagined having
sex with the actor Tim Daly oh so that's
just a personal issue for myself why not
the his thanks for sharing Daily Time
daily uh because I was told that
reference would be too old
reference is really old but it is true I
mean Obama loves men chinning his past
and you know maybe that's your become a
public figure and this is what happens
you know but it is weird love who where
did they give the level that long yeah
exactly I don't have anything of
importance in the last six months I
throw my tax returns into the streets
she was scorned for a long time to hold
on to that letter yeah oh yeah
one day I could she could have been she
could have been married to the first
African-American gay president
I mean according to the love letters
that
yes
all right coming up a cop and a cruiser
takes out a gun-wielding loser hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else